even before the official paris motor
show got underway volkswagen was here to
present its new models to the press and
the new passat gte was the star of the
evening
just like its best-selling cousin the
gulf gte is a plug-in hybrid drive this
time in the mid-size class
in e-mode the passat gte has a range of
up to 50 kilometers after that the
combustion engine takes over with a full
tank and battery the range is about 1
000 kilometers that would take you from
paris to london and back again
the seal
volkswagen martin vintacorn says the
passat gte is another step in the
direction of meeting europe's goal to
reduce passenger car emissions to 95
grams of co2 per kilometer by 2020.
hybrid cars can help make that happen so
vw is investing in the technology
bmw's slogan at the paris motor show
this year is let the sun shine in and
one of the sunniest ways to do that is
with the new 2-series convertible
bmw's how about diese calls it the
sportiest and most dynamic convertible
in its class
it's grown a bit and features more
comfort and a very powerful engine with
over 300 horsepower the m235i is the
first performance model in this segment
prices for the 2 series convertible
start at close to 36 000 euros for the
2-liter gas-powered model with 184
horsepower
the open top 4 seater will go on sale
just in time for the 2015 season
the soft top roof is electrically
powered so it opens and closes in just
20 seconds
opel is celebrating four world premieres
at the paris motor show the mocha
sapphire and insignia have benefited
from revamped powertrains then there's
also the slick and spirited new atom s
and as a real highlight the new corsa
opal's carl thomas neumann says the
mondial is always a hit the first corsa
debuted here 32 years ago this is the
course of 5.
audi also has a debut at the paris motor
show the new tt roadster it features a
folding cloth roof aluminum to keep
weight in check slightly reduced length
and up to 310 horsepower
like its hard top brother it sports a
sharper revamped design there's also the
signature single frame grille and
trapezoidal headlights the modular
construction also helps limit the weight
which boosts responsiveness all-wheel
drive is standard on the powerful
sportback version which sprints from
zero to 100 in less than five seconds
says the paris show is one of europe's
premier car events paris takes place on
even years in frankfurt on odd-numbered
ones so it's where audi can show europe
and the world what it's got in the works
musically accompanied by one republic
mercedes is presenting the next
generation of its b-class
available with every kind of engine
including fully electric and natural gas
a new fender and a wider twin slat grill
round out the facelift
mercedes ceo did session says the b
class has been super successful in its
three years on the market
they're aiming to set the pace again
the redesigned front end features led
headlights plus there's an upgraded
interior with bigger monitors
there's a natural gas version and a
fully electric version
that makes the b-class the most
versatile car in its segment
porsche is using paris to unveil its
fourth generation cayenne
first on stage is the cayenne s e-hybrid
the first plug-in hybrid in the premium
suv segment
it's a frugal giant officially using
only 3.4 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers that's 79 grams of co2 per
kilometer
says the problem with alternative
engines is that they still cost more
than conventional ones
the customer has to decide whether to
shell out for a more
in paris toyota confirmed its status as
one of the most innovative manufacturers
worldwide presenting some fascinating
concept cars
the world's number one car maker plans
to best the competition with a
mass-produced hydrogen engine
the yet to be named fuel cell vehicle
will be available first in japan and
from next summer in europe as well
another world premiere in paris is the
seat leon experience
with permanent all-wheel drive and
special experience badging the youngest
member of the seahad family offers
driving enjoyment that doesn't stop when
the road ends
this all-terrain wagon rides higher than
the leon st with a higher clearance to
match
the design features robust protective
covering on the side sills and wheel
wells eye catchers include the gutsy
front end with big air intakes and
integrated fog lights with turn signal
function and the front spoiler with
aluminum trim
and skoda is looking to paris to bust
out of its image of sensible and
somewhat frumpy cars
care for a t-shirt here you can create
your own design and take it home
the czech brand is also presenting its
completely revamped fabia compact in
various versions
the fabia is skoda's first model series
to display the design's evolution toward
more expression and emotion with accents
from motor racing
it's a showcase of crystalline forms
sharp lines and precision in every
detail
and the party over at mazda is
celebrating the 25th birthday of its
iconic mx-5 roadster whereas generations
2 and 3 stayed close to the mx-5's
original design the latest version is
completely reworked with a noticeably
more modern look
the hood conceals the newest high
compression gasoline engines of the sky
active series with either a six-speed
manual or coming soon automatic
transmission
and nissan is taking the vw golf head on
with its pulser series at paris it
unveiled a completely redeveloped series
featuring an extra roomy interior see
the future of driving at the paris auto
show through october 19th